all right thank you all for coming so
about me I've been working in Python
since about the year 2000 my first 12
years of Python work was in music in
fields of algorithmic music composition
and computational musicology since about
2012 I've been working in finance where
I build production systems for financial
modeling and product production at a
firm called research affiliates just
south from here in Newport Beach
California I'm also the author of static
frame which I will be talking about a
bit in this presentation so one of the
points of departure for this
presentation was the fact that the panel
is deprecated and I happen to have a lot
of legacy code that uses the panel the
panel if you don't know is actually
pandas namesake pan as far as I've heard
panel data was combined to form pan
pandas and that's how pandas got its
name however the panel is going away
while it's still being a useful
container of three-dimensional data so
now deprecated what do we do there's a
couple of options
there's x-ray there's pandas with
hierarchical indices and there's static
frame with hierarchical indices and
we'll look at these and compare some of
the options we have between these so
let's step back first and consider why
do we need more than a two dimensional
table so for example if we have a very
simple data frame here where we have
four rows each of those rows might be
observations here labeled ABC and D and
we have two observations x and y so we
can select values from this data frame
using the lock interface I call this
lock you might say LOC I say LOC we can
use the lock interface to select one
label per axis and these selections are
delimited by commas so we can select
rows and we can select columns and
they're nicely delimited by a comma in
our lock call so for example if I want
all rows from C to the end I can provide
a slice from C to the n with a one
argument lock call using a second
argument here Y I can select all rows
from C to the end and column Y alright
what about multiple tables so we might
have mold
sensors performing similar observations
and we might want to store these in a
single data structure a natural choice
is a Python dictionary so for example
here I can create a second data frame of
a similar of exact the exact same shape
and I can store this in a dictionary and
I can here I'm giving the dictionary
keys Roman numeral 1 and Roman numeral 2
and I can pull off a row from Roman
numeral 2 using the lock call of C and I
can average across these two data frames
but this gets pretty awkward here as you
can see we lose the opportunity for
contiguous arrays and we cannot easily
select across frames using this approach
so the pandas panel offers a nice
or rather offered a nice way to deal
with this it's basically a 3d frame it's
similar to a dictionary of 2d frames
with consistent indexing as we would
find with a data frame or a series and
it was available through pandas 0 to 3
so we can actually create a panel from a
dictionary of frames and here that's
what I'm doing I'm giving my previous
dictionary of 2 frames to the panel
constructor and now I have a panel and
we can see that the panel has labeled
the outer axis Roman numerals 1 & 2 is
the items the next axis the major axes
as labels a through D and the Minor axis
has labels X through Y so we can select
values from a panel you extending the
lock interface to 3 arguments where we
would select first two items than the
major index and then the minor index so
for example if we want to select all of
the outer items index and the major
index see we can do that with two
arguments with three arguments we can
select all of the outer items we can
select a major item C and minor axes X
and then we can take the mean across the
common element C across both of those
tables this is the operation we did
previously with a dictionary now you can
see it's much more readable and clear
what's going on and probably faster now
as I mentioned the panel was deprecated
in 0.23 of pandas and there was this
very nice warning given to us that
encourages us to consider using the
multi index or x-ray so let's
take that advice and see what we can do
with these two options so but look at
x-ray if you haven't used x-ray yet it's
a library built on numpy and pandas with
rich support for multi-dimensional data
arrays and data sets so there's the two
foundational objects in the x-ray
library
alternatively we can get hierarchical
indices and there we're going to look at
two implementations of hierarchical
indices we have the multi index and
pandas and the static frame index
hierarchy so we're gonna step back a
little bit and try to understand what a
hierarchical index is and before we do
that we're gonna need to understand what
an index is and before we do that we're
actually gonna need to go all the way
back to numpy because pandas is built on
the precedent of numpy a key feature of
pandas is that it adds labels to the
axis of numpy arrays but the pandas lock
interface is based on num pies getitem
and let me show you what I mean so numpy
provides a integer based selection using
the get item interface the selections
available some of them are like the
Python Lister tuples so we can take we
can select single items or we can select
slices but numpy goes further than the
standard Python Lister tupple numpy
introduced the idea as far as I know of
selecting arbitrary items through lists
of integers or boolean arrays so we can
see the examples of the four types of
selection available and numpy here I
create an array of eight elements and
first I'd simply select a single one
with an integer you're all familiar with
that I select a slice of the last two
elements then I can select I can give it
a list of index positions and select
those index positions or I can do
something more sophisticated and create
a boolean array by identifying all of
the values that they're module two
modulo two are equal to 0 that is the
even numbers and use a boolean array to
select from the array so numpy supports
n dimensional arrays which means we can
produce extremely complex structures and
we can perform the same types of
selection on each axis independently
each selection can use any of the four
selection methods and as we've seen in
other cases each of those selection
methods is separated by a comma
so for example if I have a
two-dimensional numpy array as I show
here I can select rows 1 & 3 with my
first argument to the gate item and I
can select columns from negative 2 to
the end using a slice for the second
argument to the gate item call if I have
a three dimensional array I can simply
continue the same pattern so if I want
to select specific elements I can
provide three arguments three integers
and get to one item if I want to select
the first two dimensions within with an
integer index and a slice for the third
I get an array out of that and if I want
to do something even more complex I can
select a single item from the first axis
a list of items from the second axis and
a slice from the third axis so now we're
ready to talk about what an index is the
index is an object that map's labels to
positions along and access the lock
interface exposes access to index
objects on rows and on columns and the
labels can be given with the same for
selection types that numpy provides us
with as with numpy the comma separates
selections per axis so as we've seen
before with the data frame we can use
the lock call to select two rows here a
and D and one column X all right so now
we're ready to talk about a hierarchical
index a hierarchical index is a
multi-level mapping applied to a single
axis two levels can describe
two-dimensional data three levels can
describe three-dimensional data and we
can go to and limited depth really on
each level supports the for selection
types that we've already introduced and
there is more than one way to implement
a hierarchical index so with the pandas
multi index we can create a multi index
using the from product constructor it's
going to take two intervals one here of
Roman numerals 1 & 2 the second argument
of letters ABCD that's going to take the
product of those two iterables
we can feed those to a data frame and we
can get a nice data frame that has a
hierarchical index on the rows and
columns labeled a and B and so from
everything we've seen before we know
that if we provide two arguments to the
lock call the first argument is going to
select the rows and the second argument
is going to select the columns
so in this example we're providing the
null slice as the first argument to
select all rows and we're supplying be
to select column B but what do we do
when we want to get inside of the HAR a
hierarchical index with numpy and index
objects we've seen that commas separate
the axes but how do we select the inner
depths within a single access we cannot
just add more commas it's ambiguous so
for example if I have a lock a call with
a B and C a and B could refer to the
rows and secret refer to the columns or
a could refer to the rows and B and C
could refer to the columns or we could
actually try it be trying to do some
sort of a three dimensional selection as
we've seen with numpy or the panel so we
need to delimit the hierarchical
selections within an access selection so
we need some way to group these inner
selections and here I make showing an
example using you know caret characters
but in pandas and static frame we
actually use a special object in pandas
this special object is called the index
slice in static frame we call it H vaak
so with the pandas multi index lock we
can do our index slice on one axis and
as you might expect here I provide an
index slice that's getting into the
inner specification of the hierarchical
index it's saying give me all of the
outer level Roman numerals one and two
and Rose B from each of those and then
select one column here now selecting the
rows with B we can do the same with the
two dimensional data frame so I mean
with it with a index hierarchy on both
the columns and the rows so here I
provide to index slices and again
there's two arguments the first argument
to lock is an index slice that's
grabbing the second Roman numeral and
rows a and D and the second argument to
lock is another index slice that's
grabbing all of the outer level and just
columns B so this is very clear and very
consistent almost now in general I have
a strong conviction that complexity
should be balanced with consistency and
as you can see these multiple access
multiple selection types things can get
very complicated
we want our hierarchical indices to be
consistent with non hierarchical ends
and in
and numpy selection methods this
consistency is important to me my
background is that of a software
engineer more than a data scientist so
my concern overwhelmingly is in
readability and maintainability of our
code and what I find is that the panas
implementation is not consistent so time
for a quiz what should these lock
selections do if we look at this example
we have a block that has two arguments
one is Roman numeral to run the other is
B in the second example we have a slice
and we have a B you don't have to shout
it out just try to think about what this
should do well in the first case we have
two arguments but those two arguments
Roman numeral two and B have selected
just from the rows now that violates
everything that we've seen previously in
numpy and single access selection where
the first argument refers to the rows
the second argument refers to the
columns now if we change the first
argument if the first argument just
happens to be a slice now it works as we
as we expect we get a row selection with
the first argument and a column
selection with the second argument
that's inconsistent okay here's your
next quiz I have the first case where an
index slice is being used we've seen how
index slice allows us to group inner
selections within an index with in a
hierarchical index so we see the first
example where we have an index slice
that's specifying what we would think
the outer level to be everything and
then the inner level to be B and D and
then we have in the second example a two
argument call to lock where we provide a
second argument here B so think about
what you might expect this to be all
right so in the first case we provided
one argument to lock and that was
wrapped in an index slice which we
thought would specify selection inside
of the hierarchical index but what
happens instead is that the one argument
index slice is treated as to one
specifying rows and the other specifying
columns if we provide a second argument
to the lock then this changes and
suddenly we get something closer to what
we expect and the well established
precedent of numpy which is that the
first argument refers to the rows and
the second argument refers to the
columns so as rain Manhattan
often too often says there has to be a
better way part of these inconsistencies
led me to build static frame and for a
desire for a more consistent and
explicit interface to these types of
tabular structures in static frame all
data is immutable all indices are unique
and we have comparable features and
performance of pandas it is dependent
exclusively on numpy and it's written
presently in pure Python now as the
second phase we're planning to look for
further performance enhancements but as
of this time we are just pure Python so
static frame introduces the index
hierarchy which is a new implementation
of the hierarchical index it's built
with non hierarchical indices which
ensures that it has consistent selection
features between index and index
hierarchy it also fits in with this
desire for consistent delimiting of
access specifications and the way that's
done is with H lock so H lock is similar
to the pandas index slice except it's
always required for inner depth
selection and it's always applied to
only one axis at a time SS lock is a
sibling to another object called I lock
h lock permits hierarchical selection
within a walk
i lock permits index position selection
within a lock I won't talk about eye
lock further but the two are sort of
siblings if you will so using static
frame we can create an index hierarchy
using a similar constructor to what we
saw with pandas a from product which is
going to take two intervals produce
their product and give us an index and
we can again create a static frame that
uses that on the ROS index with static
frame we have consistent access
selections so in the first example here
we're pandas did something kind of
surprising and treated the two arguments
as both applying to the ROS here static
frame says this is ambiguous i I don't
know what you're what you're trying to
do here by giving me this notation and
instructs us to actually use an H hawk
we need to specify that we want to get
inside of the hierarchical index for our
ROS another example here we see that we
can use an H lock to specify one
argument to a lock and is completely
unambiguous that
selecting within the hierarchical axis
on the rows so here we're taking an H
lock of all of the outer level and we're
taking the inner level of B and D and
again this is one argument so of course
this should apply only to the rows all
right so we're gonna now look at some
real data which is suitable for
hierarchical indexing what we're gonna
do is look at some time series from
multiple instruments with multiple
characteristics and we're gonna use
three dimensions a sensor identifier a
timestamp and a bunch of observations so
as a point of departure we're gonna use
this article from the Orange County
Register from last year this was on
December 17th almost a year ago from
today where the news reported that big
surf was possible a massive swell was
going to come
prompting National Weather Service issue
high surf advisory all right so we're
gonna see if there was a massive swell
on December 17th and use this as a as a
case to get some data to play with so if
you haven't known yet you can go to the
national data buoy center and get data
on all these buoys it's actually quite
interesting I found three buoys off the
coast of Southern California that seemed
to be plausible candidates
San Pedro San Pedro South and Santa
Monica Bay and we can pull a year's
worth of their data now it comes from
the NDB see in this slightly awkward
space delimited format so we're gonna
have to parse this and construct the
timestamps into meaningful timestamps
we're gonna convert the wave direction
degrees into compass labels and we're
going to convert the wave height and
wave period into floats what our
expectation is is that large wave
heights and large periods that's DPD
should correspond to this massive swell
we're looking for so we're gonna store
this in a three dimensional data
structure and we want confirmation from
multiple buoys that's why we want to
take you know multiple observations so
we're gonna have three buoys one year of
date/time samples and three attributes
per sample and we're going to look at a
couple three-dimensional data formats
that we can use we have the pandas panel
we have the X array data array and we
have hierarchical indices and pandas and
frame we're gonna look at 2d
hierarchical index on a frame and a 3d
hierarchical index on a series so let's
start with the panel so if we load this
data into a panel we can see the string
representation we get out of the panel
there
the Bui identifier czar coming in as the
items axis the major axis are the time
stamps and the minor axis are the
observations here D P D and wave height
w vh T now the string representation of
the panel makes exploration a little bit
difficult and that's something that
we're gonna bring up later on this is
sort of one of the challenges of
visualizing data three-dimensional or
higher dimensional data on a
two-dimensional screen so an X array we
can create the exact same structure and
we're gonna actually use the panel's 2 X
or a method to do this so it's gonna
give us a X array data array object with
coordinates labeled items major axis and
minor axes they're labeled that way
because they came from a panel that
could be labeled anything we want now
the string representation shows a bit
more information than the panel but I
would argue it's still a little bit
difficult to explore now we're ready to
look at hierarchical indices for the
same data and we can actually represent
the same three dimensional data in two
different ways using hierarchical
indices we can create a two-dimensional
hierarchical index on a frame that has
three columns where the index is a
hierarchical index of station ID and
date/time and the columns are our period
our wave height and our wave direction
we can also go further and collapse all
this information onto a single array and
use a three dimensional hierarchical
index on a series where our index
becomes station ID date time and the
attribute and the attribute is here wave
period and wave height this is where the
title of my talk comes from because it
is the case that any n dimensional array
can be reduced into a single one
dimensional array with sufficient
hierarchies but we probably don't want
to do this it will lead to undesirable
type coercion if we have everything in
one array and will often lead to
painfully so selection because you're
breaking up things
you should have kept separate to begin
with so this is generally not advisable
so here's what the data looks like in a
two dimensional pandas frame where we
have as our index the station ID and
date/time timestamps and we have wave
height the period and the wave direction
in a static frame two-dimensional frame
with a static frame frame with the
two-dimensional index we see something
very similar now with a three
dimensional index on a series again
we're packing all of the information
into one place so we have the station ID
on the outer level the time stamp in the
middle and the attribute either the
period or the wave height in the
innermost level of the index and we've
reduced everything to a single
one-dimensional array and we can do the
same thing with static frame as you see
here so it's useful to consider at this
point that representations matter
hierarchical indices provide practical
string representations and that's
important when viewing numerical or
character data on a screen a
two-dimensional layout is actually best
so one feature of hierarchical indices
is that they pack many dimensions into a
readable one dimensional representation
so now we're going to look at some
performance comparisons between these
different three-dimensional
representations and try to get an idea
of how some of the performance varies
amongst these and what the trade-offs
are when using these different
representations so we're gonna look at
three scenarios this is far from
exhaustive but we're gonna look at three
we're gonna look at a single buoy a
single day time in a single attribute
how long does it take us to drill down
to that single element a single buoy
a date time slice and the mean of a
single attribute and then we're going to
look across all buoys a date time slice
and then get the max from some selected
attributes I'm gonna be using pandas o
23.4 I know this is a couple versions
back but it was the last with a fully
functioning panel so that's why I chose
it and a recent version of static frame
we're gonna do five hundred iterations
of these for each of this test we're
going to give and the code to reproduce
all of this is available within the
static frame library you can find it
there so again interface is important
let's look at the interface we can see
our single buoy single date
I'm single attribute selection on a
panel and on the X or a date array is
exactly the same these two lock calls
are exactly the same and consistent with
what we've generally seen we're
selecting one axis at a time first the
station ID then the time stamp and then
the attribute we're looking for here
that's wave heights for a two
dimensional frame either in pandas or
static frame we can use an index slice
with pandas to select the outer and the
inner component of the ROS index and
then wave height from the columns from
static frame we're going to use an H
lock to do the same for the three
dimensional indices on Ceres we provide
all three arguments in one go for pandas
we don't have to wrap this in anything
it's going to just assume that that's
correct somehow for static frame because
we're more strict we're gonna require
that to be wrapped in an H lock because
we are specifically reaching into a
hierarchical index so here are the
results from this first test we see that
direct selection of a 3d index is fast
we're just drilling down into single
values and both the static frame and
pandas three-dimensional index on a
series here is actually pretty fast the
panel is faster than the pandas
dataframe with a 2d index that's a trend
we're gonna see and we could consider
that the static frame index hierarchy
may have some advantages here but I'm
not too wedded to that claim um moving
on so if we look at a single bui a date
time slice and a single attribute mean
so here we're using a feature of date
time indices where we can give it a date
and it will select all of the
observations across that day so we're
actually picking up a slice of date time
observations across an entire day and
this is one of our targeted days
December 17th by the way so we can take
a mean from both a panel or from an X
array with the same exact interface for
a two-dimensional index on a frame again
we use index slice or H lock depending
if we're using pandas or static frame
and again in this case the interfaces
are identical for working with the
three-dimensional index on a series in
this case I couldn't get pandas to match
the entire date for one reason or
another so I actually had to construct a
slice between the time stamps
for static frame we can just give the
date and everything works consistently
as we would expect so in this case the
static frame two-dimensional index
performed pretty well with the panel was
again faster than the pandas dataframe
with a two-dimensional or
three-dimensional index and we start to
see three-dimensional indices start to
really suffer and pandas
three-dimensional interface suffering
quite a bit so as you might expect with
the depth of our index growing we have
to do more and more selections to get at
those inner values and that begins to
get costly alright our last performance
test is looking at all the buoys a
date/time slice and we want to get the
max value from that slice so in the
panel and in the x-ray date array you
the interface is kind of the same but
the axes kind of flip in a funny way so
I have to provide different access
arguments here to get the same results
for the two-dimensional index on a frame
pandas and Static frame are basically
identical and how they present the way
to get this value and when we move to on
a three dimensional index on this series
things get a little bit tricky because
we want to get the max from two
attributes so we actually need to
iterate over those attributes select a
value take the max and we actually have
to do that twice so as you might expect
those are gonna get pretty slow so in
this case the panel wins the panel is
the fastest and yet again outperforms
the data frame the static frame
two-dimensional index on the frame does
pretty well X array is is similar to the
kind of in the middle as it's been and
we start to see as we get to the three
dimensional indexes a serious
degradation and performance static
frames multi index really suffering at
this high def so what we see here is
that the panel consistently outperforms
comparable data frames the x-ray data
array has performance and interface
similar to panel and that's pretty good
static frame is sometimes faster than
pandas some 2d index operations appear
to have advantages the 3d index
operations are far slower I don't put
too much credence in these performance
tests they are rather shallow but it
does give us some interesting
indications
again the static frame is pure Python
now as you probably know pandas has lots
of si and scythe on under it so we will
be looking to do performance
enhancements to static frame in the
future so again these performance tests
are shallow we could explore larger data
scales we could perform alternative
selection combinations and we could look
at different memory usage to get at what
we're doing under the hood here so to
return to where we started the panel is
deprecated what next for the most
similar performance and interface using
X array is a great choice if you are
refactoring your code as I am doing
right now to get the panel out of our
code consider moving to static frame if
the pandas dataframe with the multi
index in fact may be slower then x-ray
your previous panel code and possibly
static frame in some cases so let's
return to this guy big surf possible
flooding and erosion massive swell can
we find that massive swell in this data
well we can and I actually took a very
simple approach here we have again in a
static frame the two to three
dimensional data with a two dimensional
a hierarchical index on the rows what
I'm gonna do here is first take the mean
across all buoys using the two argument
call to look and I'm gonna add two times
the standard deviation to get a
threshold for wave height I'm gonna do
the same to get a threshold for wave
period but here I'm just gonna use one
standard deviation and I found this
through experimentation so I found two
thresholds around the mean plus or minus
one you know one or two standard
deviations and I'm gonna use a boolean
selection on a lock all I'm doing the
boolean intersection of two boolean
arrays where I find the values that are
greater than the thresholds I found and
that gives me a bunch of target records
and we can see those target records
there so now all I need to do is reduce
the time stamps in two dates so I'm
going to do that by iterating over the
values in the index and calling date on
them to get a date object and then I can
simply do a group by on the dates and
apply a length function one of the
features of static frame is that
iteration and function application are
unified in every case there aren't two
functions for those with
confusing names so we can intergroup on
date and then we can apply a length
function and this gives us a series that
shows us that in fact on December 17th
and December 18th the number of high
wave periods and high wave heights was
actually truly massive and actually you
know some of the highest days by far
across the entire year so use x-ray if
you want something similar to the panel
hierarchical indices do add overhead and
of course the more depth the more
overhead but what we've seen is that two
level depths are pretty efficient it's
also useful to consider that the string
representation of the hierarchical index
actually matters and helps in data
exploration finally consider using
static frame if you care about immutable
data you want more consistent interfaces
and in some cases maybe better
performance thank you any questions what
do you think is causing the 3d static
frame to be slower than the other two
well we see that the three-dimensional
index is always slower when we start
getting at the inner level the the three
the static frame index is built with
just Python dictionaries so we're we're
we're bound by the dictionary lookups
and we're at the inner level we have to
do a bunch of those as you may know
pandas has its own dictionary
implementation that they've refined and
specialized over the years so but
actually they're I don't even think
they're actually using that in their
hierarchical index they're doing
something kind of different so that's
something for us to look to for
performance improvements so I'm I'm
curious to know if you've ever tried
running something similar it's a query
similar to this with just loading the
data into an in-memory sequel Lite
database and running a sequel query
against it just to get a sense of what
the the kind of performance you get
there versus all these different all
these different approaches yeah that
would be that would be great to look at
of course with sequel Lite we don't
really have a hierarchical index so we
would have to layout the data in some
other way or do something a little bit
different I I did benchmark this against
pure numpy using just direct selection
through dictionaries and numpy wins
hands down in every case I didn't show
it here to keep things simple but numpy
direct is by far
fastest um SQLite we use SQLite
sometimes for similar cases but fitting
hierarchical indices in SQLite becomes
awkward obviously ok good times Thanks
yeah anything else
great thank you thank you
[Applause]